bitcoin price i have a crystal ball i've
called the bitcoin top twice okay like
basically on the day
and no one else does like they'll get it
wrong they're just they think oh we're
going to them you're saying you've seen
the when it hit 60 it's i have the
evidence okay i don't delete my calls i
said this is the top let me
so make a prediction now where is it
where is bitcoin going in the next 24
months
down to 11k down to 11. that's that's
the bottom yeah and then at the top you
think in the next 24 months well it's on
its s-curve it's the top of a test curve
but no one realizes it so the world's
richest guy bought el salvador made it
legal tender everyone and their mother
bought and after they all bought the
price barely moved up and only didn't it
went from a 20k all-time high five years
ago to a 69k now yeah it did a three and
a half x
it's all-time high in five years
meanwhile hex did 10 000 x and ethereum
did you know so like from the kova dip
ethereum went from 88 to 5 000 and
bitcoin went from 3 800 to 69 000. so
ethereum outperformed bitcoin 3x
and and is likely to continue to do so
this is superior technology so are you
based on
sort of your tone are you are you not a
fan of bitcoin are you not i think so i
think bitcoin's garbage guard's better
than the s p500 yeah it destroys the
environment the more valuable it is the
more the environment destroys pulse
chain solves this
um
it
is slow it's expensive
it has no road map it has no anonymity
you know it has no stable coins on it it
has no tokens on it it has no time
deposit on it the fans are rabid
scumbags like they just they're like you
know if you like anything other than
bitcoin you're demon well there's
bitcoin maximalists right yeah they're
scumbags
explain this is not my world i mean i'm
in the money game regular but not crypto
crypto seems to be very tribal
right there's like you're like you the
people that follow you and the follow
hacks are like
you know whether you're a bitcoin person
there's people that believe in ethereum
and all the everything the capabilities
that can happen with that there were
doge point coin the safe mode all this
stuff that's out there why is crypto so
tribal and what what is what
differentiates hex that's better than
you're saying you're basically saying
bitcoin ain't [ __ ] ethereum's nothing
and all these other well no ethereum is
pretty badass that's what i'm copying it
gotcha all right so explain the tribal
of crypto and
the the the pros and cons of what you're
seeing out there
you have light tribalism in
stuff like apple versus android
ford vs chevy you've got light tribalism
there you've got more advanced tribalism
in sports team burst sports team people
get the tattoos they wear the stuff
right but the yankees red socks the
whole thing
celtics lakers
the issue is that
in those particular uh
collectivisms
they're not your life savings right and
when someone else defects from your team
and hurts the price now your life
savings are injured gotcha now there's
money on the line they're skipping the
game it's not just hey i'm rooting for
my team right so the tribalism is even
that more enhanced as well yeah people
people and even if you didn't put your
life savings in these things appreciate
in value so much that it becomes your
life savings unless you're constantly
selling got it because you would have to
constantly sell
to try and maintain that as a small
portion because it outperforms
everything else like there's no question
unless you bought the top and then if
you're following me you probably didn't
um so i think that's very important that
you point out if you bought the top if
you bought bitcoin at 69 and now it's at
22.
you're like richard what the are you
talking about because you should have
followed me on twitter twitter.com
richard hartwin
could have saved you from that
so
it's like now that tribalism you have to
ask yourself is it useful or is it
non-useful and the answer is
both
it stops people from buying scams that's
good so if you're bitcoin maximalist
you're not going to buy scams because
bitcoin is a nice camp it's at the top
of s-curve it dumps as hard as
everything else and it doesn't pump as
hard its pumps get lower and lower every
single cycle it's too heavy now it's
slow it's old there's no improvements to
it etc but
it still works and it's still better
than getting scammed unlike celsius
which is bankrupt or luna which went to
zero or
you know all these other things i've
warned people about that they don't
listen i begged people to remove their
coins from celsius really cryptocurrency
was invented to remove middlemen
of course you give your coins to someone
else and you beg and hope that they give
you more back no that's the opposite of
why crypto's invented and i specifically
invented a product to let you earn
interest and generate yield holding your
own keys no one can screw you out of
them like your keys or your keys
no one can ever stop you from minting
your own rewards it's perfect it's
flawless it's amazing it directly solves
all these people trying to earn seven or
eight percent yield
and then losing everything because the
guy that said he was going to pay the
yield he runs out with the cash so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]